[Music]
[Applause]
now
mike florio from pro football talk live
joining us on the program
mike let me start with deshaun watson i
said from the outset i wasn't getting
into the salacious details with desean
watson i was trying to look at it from a
football perspective
of when he'll play if he'll play where
he'll play
and uh but you know i read something
that you wrote yesterday and you were
kind of looking at both of these lawyers
with what they're saying and how they're
framing certain things here
and i thought it would be you know
really beneficial to the audience to at
least
understand where we are right now and
where you think we're going to be headed
with deshaun watson
well dan two courts in a situation like
this the court of law in the court of
public opinion and a lot has been
playing out in the court of public
opinion
the only thing that's played out in a
court of law so far
19 lawsuits filed and the way that it
works
the civil complaint gets filed once
service
is performed and in this case rusty
hardin the lawyer for
deshaun watson accepting actual process
that
starts the clock on a response you can
file an answer
to the allegations and there will be 19
of them in this case
you can file a motion in response to the
complaint i won't be surprised if there
isn't some type of an
effort by rusty harden to challenge all
of these complaints
based upon the fact that they've been
filed under a pseudonym that has been
one of the complaints we've seen
publicly
from rusty hardin and i'm not commenting
on the accuracy of any of the
allegations here i'm talking about the
legal mechanics
he could file a motion to dismiss a
motion for a more
definite statement something aimed at
finding out
who the individuals are who are making
these claims because he's complained
about that
that tactic so many times in his public
statement so
there could be a motion to dismiss on
that basis at some point though
the battle is officially joined the
court sets a trial date
and it all moves forward with the
discovery process
deposition testimony people people
telling their versions under oath
documents being obtained
text messages etc typically takes 18
months to two years in most
jurisdictions for it to resolve so
barring a settlement and i've advocated
publicly
repeatedly the best thing for desean
watson have his reckoning make this
right satisfy whatever concerns these
individuals have and move on
otherwise it's going to hover over him
the texans in the league for two years
dan
are the police involved well
the criminal courts are not yet involved
and this is where it gets a little
confusing there was a social media post
last night from tony busby who
represents
all 19 of the plaintiffs suggesting that
he didn't go through with his vow to
submit evidence to the houston police
department
because he's got concerns that he ran
for mayor and
there may be some i look i i it's the
height of cynicism to suggest that
there would be 19 individuals 19 who
have
concerns that the law was violated and
that those concerns would not
properly be processed and handled by the
houston police because
somebody doesn't like tony busby and if
that's the case if there's any truth to
that then these 19 women should be
represented by someone else
if the lawyer is going to be an
impediment to them getting justice
in criminal court now dan i'll say this
as it stands now
the very high bar of proof beyond a
reasonable doubt that applies
in criminal cases i think it's difficult
to satisfy that
based upon the allegations we've seen
and the evidence that seems to be out
there which comes down to
one person's word against another's but
if you go forward with the civil cases
deshaun watson has a hell of a decision
to make if there's a possibility of
prosecution
and you get put under oath in the civil
case what are you going to do you're
going to invoke your
right against self-incrimination under
the fifth amendment you're basically
forfeiting the civil case if you do that
but if you talk and you get twisted in
knots by an aggressive lawyer
you may give a prosecutor a road map for
trying to put you behind bars
that's another reason why i say the best
thing for him to do find a way
to get these cases resolved to the
satisfaction of the individuals
i'm not saying make it go away i'm
saying deal with it
deal with it resolve it otherwise it can
lead to all sorts of problems down the
road if it's september
given what deshaun watson is going
through right now is desean watson
in uniform in september let me preface
this by saying dan that under the
policies that the nfl has available to
it it can do whatever it
wants and precedent doesn't really
matter every case
is treated individually and it's all
driven by
pr personal conduct policy commissioner
exempt list it's all about
how does it make the nfl look most
employers vast majority
don't care what you do away from work
think about that
all this conduct is away from the
workplace but the nfl and the nfl
players association have agreed
that these things that happen away from
work can affect the way the players are
viewed the teams are viewed the league
is viewed so
discipline is available commissioners
exemplists paid leave i firmly believe
that if these cases are still hovering
when september rolls around haven't been
resolved moving forward in the civil
justice system
that the league will strongly consider
putting deshaun watson on paid leave
and that would be the ultimate irony
here he's wanted out of houston so badly
that may be his only financial lifeline
this year getting 10 million
plus to not play while on paid leave
and that 10 million is going to come in
handy if he's defending
what is now then according to the
houston chronicle 21
assault lawsuits that have been filed
against him and who knows how many more
there will be
commissioners said we're going to have
fans in the stands uh to start the
season
is that uh kind of across all
platforms here all teams all states that
they're going to be able to have
a capacity i think it's wishful thinking
in some states obviously texas florida
you're going to have full stadiums no
matter what the status of the pandemic
is that's not a political comment that's
just a fact
other states they may be a little more
hesitant i think what the commissioner
may be trying to do here dan is speaking
into existence in some of these states
that may be less inclined to say full
attendance
is permitted we've got a long way to go
before we get to september we've got a
lot of progress we still need to make
when it comes to the pandemic
recently the news hasn't been good it
fluctuates
as more people get vaccinated but five
months
is a lifetime as far as the pandemic is
concerned there's reason for optimism
but there's still a lot more that needs
to be done and specifically you've got
to convince
california new york massachusetts other
state and local governments
that it's okay not just to have some
fans present but to have a full capacity
your biggest concern with the 17 game
schedule is
i don't know that i have a concern per
se because the bottom line is the
players voted for it the league was
determined to get
it they were going to get it my biggest
expectation is it's a stopover to 18.
and it's just a matter of when the
league makes the push
for 18 will it be when this current cba
expires will it be before that
one of the things about the new tv deals
dan the league has the ability to pull
the plug on all of them seven years in a
one-time
out i fully expect the league to take
that out and that's a spot where you can
say
we have another weekend of games for you
we want more money for that the gambling
side of it has continued to grow we
think the rights are more valuable and i
think that that
proliferation of gambling is about 20
states now 22 states
it's going to get to 30 35 40. i think
the hard ceiling is 44 because there's
only 44 states now that have lotteries
but once we get more and more states
more and more money more and more
revenue
more and more football i think 18 is
is is inevitable they still want 18 they
just decided that 17
is the easier sell for now everybody get
paid
as far as the players go do you get an
extra check with an extra game
i think they hashed that all out and it
was so long ago i have to go back and
refresh my memory they came up with a
deal where you get an extra check at the
rate you were supposed to make although
there may be a cap on that for some
players that would be unfair
i think the bottom line is you should
get one more check at the same rate that
you were already
due to make for playing that extra game
and i think anything less than that
would be patently unfair
talking to mike florio pro football talk
live co-host
you know this whole these pro days and
yeah and i know you don't
you know do deep dives into these kind
of things
but you know we're seeing this play out
where san francisco goes up
and we assume they're taking mack jones
and then mack jones maybe didn't
perform as well as he should have
yesterday and then justin fields plays
or
performs really well here does is any of
this going to matter
when we get to the draft in less than a
month i don't think it ultimately does
now the difference between this year and
other years dan there's no opportunity
for the private workout where any
concerns that a team may have
could be alleviated i remember in 2014
teddy bridgewater did his pro day
workout
without his gloves and it was a disaster
well then the vikings did
a private workout with him he put the
gloves on and they fell in love with him
and so that was that problem solved
we're seeing guys do multiple pro day
workouts this year so
so coaches can come and and watch what
they do like kyle shanahan and john
lynch yesterday in tuscaloosa
and i don't read a whole lot into
anything that happens
sims and i were talking about it earlier
today on the overthrow
that drew the flashback by kyle shanahan
to jimmy garoppolo missing emmanuel
sanders in super bowl 54.
i mean we don't know if the guy ran the
route too slow if he pulled up at the
end if he wasn't going to lay out
and risk injuring himself trying to
catch that ball
it wasn't a horrible like missed him by
20 yards overthrow and if anything you'd
rather overthrow than under throw and if
he under throws it the guy slows down
and catches it you say hey he completed
a pass in a game
you throw that ball it's possibly going
to be picked off by the safety
yeah i know it's we're told reminded
don't read too much into these pro days
and then all of a sudden you start to
see
some of the new york media saying should
the jets reconsider
zach wilson at number two and maybe
justin fields
just based off him but that feels
that field's throw he's running right to
left
and he's throwing the ball in the
direction he's running and he puts
his entire body into that throw the zack
wilson throw that got everyone fired up
he's going right to left and he sends it
back the other way with a flick of the
wrist
that's why sims has wilson at number one
on his board of quarterbacks
because he sees mahomes and rogers in
the things wilson can do
effortless flick of the wrist 60 yards
down the field
yeah it's called mahomezian i've i've
coined the phrase
mahomesean throws
i like that okay i'll use that you can
take it i mean it doesn't matter i mean
i
thank you i'm john stockton send you
something every time i say it no no no
no no no no but you know i just i just
like john stockton i just i'll throw it
to you you can be carl malone
but there's gonna be a whole generation
of kids seriously who who have watched
patrick holmes i mean well michael
jordan did the basketball patrick
mahomes is going to do the quarterback
position
there's going to be you know 5 10 15
years from now more and more guys who
come into the nfl
playing like mahomes and already here
comes a guy zach wilson who can play
like mahomes
it's going to revolutionize the game
when there are enough of those guys
playing quarterback that that's the kind
of stuff we see
any body position any arm angle just
these incredible
throws where the ball just gets rifled
down the field with a flick of the wrist
it's
awesome it's great for the future of the
game well mahomes is doing for
quarterbacks what steph curry is doing
for shooters
and steph curry to me has had the
biggest impact
on the nba in in a long time even
bigger from the standpoint than jordan
from that everybody thinks they can do
what steph curry does nobody knew nobody
thought they could do what jordan did
with mahomes these quarterbacks all
think that they can do what mahomes does
or they can at least try to do that
um you know that that what i think is
you know the impact that these two are
going to have on their respective sports
that's right because a certain
percentage of the quarterbacks who try
will realize they can do it they'll
practice it they'll work on it
and then the next thing you know you got
another patrick holmes and another
patrick holmes
and and it bodes very well for the
future of the sport and dan you know
five years ago
i would have said there's no way in hell
they're going to expand the nfl because
there aren't enough quarterbacks
i think we're getting to the point where
there's enough quarterbacks and i'm
telling you
once they get to 18 games the next way
you increase inventory for gambling
purposes into is to increase teams
just wait for it it's coming 34 36
they're going to start talking about it
and once they start talking about it you
know they've got a plan in place
okay but where are we expanding to
well i i think that the overseas markets
need to be taken seriously two teams in
london maybe elsewhere peter king
suggested last night a full division of
four teams that would be international
and there's always a market or two in
the us you could drop a team in san
diego
you could drop a team in st louis
although st louis is currently suing the
nfl for
a lot of money they'd have to mend those
fences first and i've said for years the
prospect of a second team in chicago and
they got two baseball teams
right why couldn't you put a second nfl
team in chicago
and so i i just think that the push
to have more football content that's
televised
with in-game betting play-by-play
betting
more more and more they'll find places
to put teams
yeah they got to get one good team in
chicago and then i think that you can
expand that
mic up so it would be the expansion team
yeah yeah
they haven't had two good teams in new
york for a decade well i mean you know i
mean look at the
the jets haven't done anything and the
giants since they won the super bowl 10
years ago been to the playoffs one time
so we suggested they merge we thought
that maybe if they merged they might be
a playoff team
that's but you know what hey zach if
they if they don't screw up this zach
wilson thing
the jets may finally have their joe
namath all these years later
thank you mike as always thanks dan
sorry about the technical issues buddy
that's mike florio pro football talk
live